Lea Michele snapped with her new man
robert buckley for the first time only
et has the pics of their night out
you've been out spotted with not only
looking amazing pretty handsome eye
candy oh yeah Leah you have a scream
queen star trying to avoid the cameras
outside of posh a restaurant in LA on
Thursday night I guess that's the best
way to put it
rub looking at her his arm partially
around her the new couple was on a
double date with Leah's BFF and former
Glee co-star Becca Tobin and her fiance
Zack Martin a source tells été the group
was laughing and having fun and that Rob
introduced Leah to someone as his
girlfriend
our source also adds Leah and Rob have
been dating for a couple of months and
are quote totally crazy about each other
we asked Leah about Rob earlier this
month she adorably dodged the question
you know I'm just feeling really great
right now and super happy I feel very
very very lucky and grateful in my life
right now and that's all that matters a
little blushing going on Leah I don't
know it's just really good bronzer